عندما أبلغنا آخر مرة عن محنة
المترجمين
العراقيين والأفغان الذين خلفتهم الحكومة الأمريكية ، ياسين من أجل سلامته الشخصية ، وليس
اسمه الحقيقي الذي
اتصل بي مختبئًا وخائفًا
على حياته ،
فأنا دائمًا ما أختبئ ، نعم أنا وعائلتي
وقلق.  ويخاف على
كل شيء
حسنًا ، كان ياسين مترجمًا
للجيش الأمريكي في العراق من 2009 إلى 2011
متزوج ولديه طفل واحد أمضى
سنوات في محاولة الحصول على
تأشيرة الهجرة الخاصة للولايات المتحدة
التي وعد بها لخدمته
لوضع حياته على  خط
ست سنوات ولم يتصل بي أحد ، لم يتصل بي أحد
من منظمة آيوم لإجراء مقابلة أولى ،
كانت آخر تهديدات بالقتل
من المتمردين قبل أربعة أشهر
في عام 2006 ، تحدثت إلى فتاة مراهقة
اتصلنا بها سارة لتسليط الضوء على وظيفة هؤلاء
المترجمين  فعلت بالنسبة لنا
القوات ، قد تكون سارة الضئيلة
قصيرة في الطول لكنها طويلة
الشجاعة
قل لها نحن أصدقائنا الذين طلبوا منا إخفاء
وجهها
حتى لو لم أظل من بلدي ،
فأنا أخدم
إنه أمر ممتع
ولكنه خطير في نفس الوقت ، لكني
أحب ذلك فهو عمل حاسم لأن
هؤلاء الأشخاص لا يتعاملون فقط
بالكلمات التي يتعاملون معها في حياة الناس ،
الأمريكية والعراقية ، كانت سارة محظوظة من أولئك
الذين حصلوا على تلك التأشيرة الثمينة
إنها تعيش الآن في الولايات المتحدة وليس
اسمه الحقيقي ، إما متزوج وله أربعة
أطفال ،
فهو واحد من آلاف الأشخاص غير المحظوظين
بعد العمل لمدة ست
سنوات من أجل القوات الأمريكية ، ما زال ينتظره
وهو ليس شيئًا
نحن ملعونون نحن نعيش في الجحيم
تموت كل يوم ولكن ليس
حليفًا يحتضر مثل جوستين تم تهديده
حتى بإطلاق النار عليه أكثر من مرة في طريقه إلى
المنزل الذي
اعتبره الإرهابيون الأمريكيون خائنًا.
دائمًا ما يحصل الخائن والخونة على ما
يستحقونه بالنسبة لقيمة الوظيفة التي
استمع
إليها هؤلاء الأشخاص من وحدة سارة. أنا معجب
بالشجاعة ، من الصعب نوعًا ما أن تقول أنك
خائف من شيء ما عندما يكون لديك
19 عامًا  فتاة عجوز تجلس
بجانبك بنصف حجمك
ولا تخاف من أي شيء يحدث
في بغداد.
علي لديه رسالة لرئيس الولايات المتحدة الرئيس
بايدن أريدك أن تنقذ
حياتنا لأننا أنقذنا حياة ابنك
الناس في الجيش.  لا يمكننا أن
ننتظر
قتلةنا قتلةنا
سيذهبون مثل
بوم ونحن في الخارج
لن يكون هناك المزيد غدًا بالنسبة لنا
مايكل
هولمز.